all right let's go to Olivia in
California hi Olivia welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Rachel thanks so much for
taking my call sure what's up Dave I
just want to start by saying first of
all thank you so much if you have come
into my life 10 years sooner oh my god I
would be a millionaire by now
well that means 10 years from now you
will be I'm on it I am mourning I am
focused and not finished
I am a good dull intense lover here's my
question I my husband and I are
interested in moving back to the East
Coast were originally from the Catskills
and we moved to California for work but
we're finding that even though we're
making pretty decent money we can't
afford the home prices out here so we're
looking to move back to the East Coast
in February when our lease is up but we
want to know is purchasing a home right
now while we're still in baby step two
we've paid off about $30,000 in debt in
the last year but we're now at our
student loans were and then there are 67
and 22 so we want to know if moving back
to the East Coast is a good idea with
having those student loans and should we
stop the student loan payments
considering what's happening right now
with the government and put that money
towards our down payment well if I were
in your shoes Olivia I would I would
hold off on buying I think moving to the
East Coast that's a lifestyle decision
you guys want to make in February once
your lease runs up is it February right
so it'll be about another nine months
yeah nine ten months so yeah I mean by
that point you guys will be tackling
this debt you'll you know your debt load
will be less because you'll be paying on
it but if you still have that student
loan that I would I would rent or lease
something out on the East Coast but I
would still make the move I think you
can do that you'll have to account for
some expenses and things that will cause
there but I think that yeah that's a
lifestyle move that you guys can still
make but I would not purchase a home I
wouldn't save up for a down payment or
use any money you have to pay down those
student loans Olivia the reason is those
kind thirty years of doing this I've
never had someone ever who said I paid
off my dad I saved my emergency
fun I put down a down payment on home oh
that was such a big mistake but I have
met with thousands of people and taking
calls from thousands of people that say
I bought a house while I still had a
bunch of debt around my neck and the
house turned into a curse rather than a
blessing and the reason is is it just
cost money to own a house stuff breaks
and things happen and stuff comes out of
nowhere and it's a different level of
strain on you than renting and so I
would rent the cheapest thing you can
rent and that is reasonable and safe so
that you can pay off the debt even
faster so that you can buy but rachel is
exactly right I definitely would be
debt-free and have your emergency fund
plus a down payment when you buy I know
that sounds super conservative but today
in the middle of this mess
it doesn't sound conservative it sounds
reasonable because it was always
reasonable